this is session nine of the foundations
and finance module and in this session
i'd like to extend the discussion
evaluation
to contingent cash flows or options as
they're more commonly
called so let's start off by looking at
what makes an option an option
an option provides its holder with the
right to buy or sell
as specified and as a specified asset
called an underlying asset
at a fixed price any time before the
expiration of the option
so think of what goes in there there is
an underlying asset without it an option
cannot live
the price is fixed up front that price
is called the strike price
here's what makes options interesting
it's a right not an obligation
and the best way to see how options work
is what is with what's called a payoff
diagram
so let's look at the payoff diagram for
a call option
a call option gives you the right to buy
an underlying asset at a fixed price
you can use that right or exercise that
right any time through the life of the
option if you have an american option
or you can exercise it only at the
expiration of the option which is called
a european option
nothing to do with geography just
specifies when you can exercise
so the payoff diagram for a call option
looks as follows
the strike price the price at which you
can buy becomes
the tipping point if your actual stock
price is greater than that strike price
you will exercise the option and make
the difference
so for instance if you get the right to
buy at 50 you will exercise it right
only if the stock is higher than 50.
if the stock price drops below 50 you
will not exercise it's a right not an
obligation
so what you will lose is what you
originally paid
to get the option limited losses
potentially unlimited profits you see
what's different about a put option
a put option gives you the right to sell
an asset at a fixed price
any time before expiration obviously you
will exercise this right only if the
stock price drops below the strike price
and you will throw away the option and
not exercise it if the stock price rises
above
again let's think in terms of payoff
diagrams if the stock price is less than
the strike price you will exercise and
make the difference
if the stock price is higher than the
strike price you would say i'm sorry i
bought that option
and essentially write off whatever you
originally played here too the loss is
fixed
and the profits well not infinite
because the price can't drop below zero
are potentially very large
as you look at these payoff diagrams you
should already start to see the
variables that determine the value of an
option
three of those variables relate to the
underlying asset
first as the value of the underlying
asset goes up and down the value of all
options both calls and puts will go up
and down as well
and here's why you get the right to buy
at a fixed price the value of the
underlying asset goes up
call options will get more valuable put
options and you get the right to sell at
a fixed price
will get less valuable so the first
variable that drives the value of
options is the value of the underlying
asset
the second is the variance in that value
and here's where options are different
from any other type of asset
now with bonds and stocks you notice
that if i made the cash flows more risky
the value got lower risk was a bad thing
with options as i increase the risk the
variance in value
of the underlying asset both calls and
puts become more valuable
that sounds mysterious at front you're
saying how come remember those payoff
diagrams your
limited losses and potentially unlimited
profits the call option
limited losses and very large profits of
the put option
variance is now your friend because
you're protected on the downside
so the greater the variance the value of
the underlying asset the more valuable
options on that asset will become
the third is any dividends you receive
on the underlying asset can affect the
value
of the options when a stock pays a
dividend its stock price drops
so when the stock price drops remember
call options become less valuable put
options become more valuable
so if you expect dividends to be paid
out on the underlying asset reducing the
price of the asset over the life of the
option
you will reduce the value of call
options and increase the value of put
options
value of the asset variance in the value
expected dividends
all on the underlying asset there are
two variables relating to the options
that can affect its value the first is
the strike price with a call option the
right to buy at a fixed price will
become more valuable the lower that
price so the lower the strike price of a
call option the more valuable a call
option will become
the reverse is going to be true for a
put option the lower the strike price
the less valuable a put option will be
and the longer the life of an option
this is true for both calls and puts the
more valuable the option will be because
you have more time to play
the only macro variable that affects the
value of options
is the riskless rate and here's why with
both call input options especially if
your european option
you will not exercise till the end of
the option so you don't have to pay that
fixed price
if you're if you have a call option
until three months from now six months
from now you're saying so what
the higher interest rates are the lower
the present value of what you committed
to pay so call options
will become more valuable as interest
rates go up and put options will become
less valuable
because whatever you collect six months
from now is worth less now
those are the six variables that drive
the value of an option and here's where
i'm going to introduce the basics of
option pricing
option pricing models can be incredibly
complex and messy but here's what i want
you to think about
all option pricing models are built on
two building blocks
the first is the notion of a replicating
portfolio what does that mean
i can create something that looks just
like the option in terms of cash flows
by combining the underlying asset and
either borrowing or lending
so the notion of a replicating portfolio
is that you can create
using the underlying asset and a
riskless asset something that looks
exactly like your option to do this
though the underlying asset needs to be
traded
the option needs to be traded you need
to be able to borrow and lend money at
the risk-free rate
so if you can create a replicating
portfolio combination of the underlying
asset and borrowing or lending that has
the same cash flows the option
the second leg of option pricing models
kick in it is
that if these two assets have the same
cash flows the option in the replicating
portfolio they have to trade at the same
price
now the easiest way to think about this
replicating portfolio is to put
is to make it go from the abstract
reality
i can create something that looks like a
call option by borrowing money
and buying a certain number of shares of
the underlying stock
i can create something that looks like a
put by selling short a certain number of
shares in the underlying stock and
lending money
now you're saying well a certain number
of shares how many shares how much do i
need to borrow and lend
that's effectively what every option
pricing model is trying to do
is to come up with that replicating
portfolio the simplest way to see an
option pricing model at play
is with what's called a binomial option
model in a binomial option model here's
what
here's what you have you have a stock
that can move to one of two points at
the next time period so let's suppose
you have a stock trading at 50.
the next time period the stock can
either go to 70 or drop to 35
if it goes to 17 the following time
period can jump to 100 or drop to 50.
if it goes to 35 it can jump back up to
50 or drop to 25.
it's called binomial because in every
leg you can go to only one of two prices
now here's what i'm going to try to do
i'm going to look at a call option with
a strike price
of 40 on this stock which is going to
expire t equal to 2.
the way you value options is you always
start with the end node when the option
is exercised know what the cash flows
are and you work
backwards so let's say you have a strike
a
call with a strike price of 40. if the
stock goes to 100 that call is going to
give you 60 dollars in cash flows right
you'll buy it 40 and sell it 100. if the
stock goes to 50 you'll get 10 and the
stock goes to 25 you will not exercise
the option your gross cash flow will be
zero here's what you're trying to do
with the replicating portfolio you're
trying to create a combination
of the stock and borrowing that'll have
exactly the same cash flows as the call
so let's move one leg back
to where the stock is trading at 70. i'm
trying to create
a combination of stock and borrowing
that will create exactly the same cash
flows as a call
for purpose of abstraction let's call
the number of shares you buy
d and the amount you borrow b hang in
there for a moment you'll see exactly
what i'm trying to do
so you're going to go out and buy these
shares of stock when the stock is 70 and
borrow b
dollars let's say the interest rate is
a period thereafter you've got to pay
the borrowing back that's the b
times 1.11 is the borrowing payback and
if the stock goes to 100
the d shares of stock you bought will be
worth 100 times t
a hundred times d minus the borrowing
paid back with interest has to be equal
to 60.
if the stock goes to 50 50 times d minus
the borrowing paid back with interest
has to be equal to 10. replicating
portfolio same cash flows
two equations two unknowns you solve for
it here's what you get
d is equal to one b is 36.04
what does it even mean if you go out
when the stock is 70 and you borrow 36
dollars and four cents and buy one share
of stock
you've created a replicating portfolio
that is going to have exactly the same
cash flows
as a call with a strike price of 40.
it's going to cost you 33.96 to create
this replicating portfolio
think of why you go out and buy a share
it's going to cost you 70. but since you
borrowed 36.04
it's a difference you got to come up
with that 33.96
has to be equal to the what the call is
trading for
because that's the arbitrage principle
kicking i have a value for the call if
the stock goes to 70.
i repeat this process if the stock goes
to 35
i set up d and b i solve for d and b and
if the stock goes to 35 i need to buy
point four shares of stock
and borrow nine dollars and one cent to
replicate the option
that cost me four dollars and ninety
nine cents to create that becomes the
value of the call
the stock goes to 35 at the value of the
call 3396 the stock goes to 70. the
value of the call
of 4.90 in 99 cents if it goes to 35
i can now go back to my initial node
repeat the process
go out and borrow d borrow b and in this
case i'm trying to make sure the values
i get
if the stock goes to 70 and the stock
goes to 35
are 33 96 and 4.99 now you can already
see
why you have to start at the end nodes
and work backwards and if i solve for d
and b at the current time i get d equal
to 0.8278 and b equal to 21.67
if i go out and borrow 21.61
today and buy 0.8278 shares of stock
i've created not just a replicating
portfolio but it'll cover
every one of my costs from this point on
that replicating position today it's
going to cost me 19.42
that becomes the value of the call today
replication
arbitrage you can already see that this
can become a very tedious process if i
have a three-month option i make time
one minute think of how many
how many little legs there will be in my
binomial tree
in fact as t gets smaller
if i assume the price changes also get
smaller that's called a continuous price
distribution
this binomial distribution becomes the
normal distribution
and the the option pricing model the
binomial option pricing model actually
becomes the black show
the black shoals and i'll talk about
this that in a moment
is if time becomes smaller price changes
remain large prices can still jump
then the limiting distribution is going
to be some kind of a jump process
distribution option pricing gets a lot
messier
it's much easier working with a normal
and a continuous distribution
and while it cuts some corners make some
assumptions that's part of the reason
people continue to use the black shoals
it's a much more convenient model to use
because
it's much easier to work with than a
binomial you're saying what's in the
black shells
the black scholes model actually
predates the binomial in the black
scholes model
the value of a call option is a function
of five variables
s which is the value of the underlying
asset k which is the strike price
t which is the life of the option r
which is the riskless rate
and sigma squared which is the variance
in the value of the underlying as
five variables but if you remember there
were six variables
that i said affected the value of
options notice the missing variable here
the missing variable here is is
is dividends right the original black
shoals was designed to value
dividend protected options because
mathematically it is easier to do
and in the original black shows here's
what you have the value of a call
is s which is the value of the
underlying asset today times
n of d1 you say what's n of d1 if i turn
very quickly to the next page
n of d1 is an area under the normal
distribution
and if you look at to the right you
actually see the this is a cumulative
normal distribution basically looks at
the area
and that number is a number between
minus 1 and plus 1. it's like a
probability that's what the end of d1 is
so s times n of d1 minus k
minus rt you're saying what is that if
you remember when we talked about time
value in continuous time e minus rt is a
present value factor
i'm taking the present value of the
strike price because i don't have to pay
the strike price till expiration
the original black trolls was designed
to value european options which can be
exercised only at expiration
so i take the present value of the
exercise price and i multiply by n of d2
another area under the distribution how
do i know what that area is
you compute d1 and d2 and if you look at
d1 and d2 mathematically they may seem
messy
but look at the variables that go into
them s k all of the variables that drive
the value of the option are in d1 and d2
so here's how you sequence it
you get skrt and sigma you plug them in
and get d1 and d2
you go to the distribution you convert
the d1 and d2 into n of d1 and n and d2
then you plug it in you got a value for
the call i know
there are legions of people who plug and
chug with black trolls models but
embedded in the black shoals model
is the replicating portfolio you're
saying where
remember the replicating portfolio you
borrow money and you buy a certain
number of shares
in the black shows here's how you read
the black shells ke minus rt times
nd 2 becomes what you borrow n of d1 is
the number of shares
of the underlying asset that you buy
it's called the option delta
almost everything you do in option
pricing is built around the replicating
portfolio
and you see that when you look at the
equation
now of course the original black shows
did not adjust for dividends and some of
the options in fact many of the options
you may be pricing
might have a dividend in the underlying
asset there's a simple way to
incorporate into option pricing if
you're willing to make an assumption
if you're willing to assume that the
dividend yield remains constant over the
life of the option here's what you can
do
you can bring dividends into the process
by first taking the current stock price
and reducing it for the expected
dividends over the life remember we said
when dividends get paid out the stock
price gets reduced
s e minus y y t is just the stock price
discounted for the so it's the stock
price adjusted for future dividend
payments
and the other thing that happens your
carrying costs become smaller and here's
what
when you go out and borrow money now you
can now make some of the
interest payments with the dividends you
receive on the underlying stock
so the r minus y so in the d1 and d2 you
now have a y
incorporated if you make those changes
you have a very
easy way of adjusting the black shells
for dividends
incidentally if you know the value of a
call getting to the value of a put is
relatively simple because
calls and puts are linked to the hip
with what's called put call parity
and in fact if you can value calls you
should always be able to derive the
value for put from the value of a call
so here's something to keep in mind the
black scholes model was designed for a
restrictive environment
stocks that don't pay dividends and
european options that said
its simplicity is its biggest selling
point it has those five variables you
plug them and you come up with the value
of the black shells
a binomial model is a much more flexible
model it allows for early exercise
but it requires a lot more work to fill
in the nodes
if you are willing to cut those corners
the black scholes model
will work reasonably well in terms of
telling you
what the value of an option is in fact
it might give at least a floor on your
option
pricing value because most options are
american options can be exercised early
so i know this was a speedy introduction
to option pricing
but we can build on this as we go
through this process both in corporate
finance and in valuation